scusi possiamo ordinare abbiamo subito
scusi per ordinare dati che della mia
collega possa portarvi dell'acqua
naturale frizzante allora vi avviso che
abbiamo finito il risotto la zuppa e gli
antipasti della casa tutti secondo di
carne di pesce e dolci allora la signora
e cieli agassi allora potremo andare su
un spaghetti allo scoglio che pesce
pesce può mangiarlo sì non ci dovrebbero
essere problemi sennò una pizza kamut
invece il passo normale che è molto più
leggera il risotto tricolore fatto con
il riso poi c'è il basilico perché verde
immagino il pomodoro e del formaggio no
non lo so che formaggio c'è se proprio
vuole vada a chiedere in cucina come non
avete ordinato questo scusi ho sbagliato
tavolo quindi due espressi 3
decaffeinati 4 macchiati di cui due con
latte di soia è un caffè lungo allora
non erano quattro i macchiati allora
alzate la mano per i macchiati la
password e wifi e vorremmo andare a casa
quando cavolo vi alzate sì tutto
maiuscolo tutto attaccato